i i think it's interesting i mean you've
previously talked about how you don't
think you look anything like robert
evans and we're surprised that they
wanted you to be in this
but clearly you signed on jumped in and
did it anyway so was that challenge part
of the appeal
well i've definitely reached the part of
my life now um where
i've realized that sometimes you just
got to do what's really scary rather
than being a self-saboter
and i've had a few opportunities
none of which i will name
but where i where i got scared and just
thought no and then someone's gone to
win an oscar so um
it's a brilliant story and i should be
so lucky and
and i think the fact that it came from
so left field i was originally given the
script and it was and it was to look at
a different part and i and i never got a
phone call about when the audition would
be and so i just thought well i'll watch
it when it comes out and it'll be
whoever it is and then
and then i got phoned up and said dexter
and nicki would like you to play robert
evans and i was like
and so and i think that's what you need
occasionally is someone to bestow that
upon you
and you just go well if they feel i can
do it then i'll give it my best shot
and also
dexter is incredibly charming and um
and i felt like well if he thinks i can
do it then he then i must be able to do
it he's got a kind of superpower when it
comes to actors and maybe it's because
he does that himself but i genuinely
think
he's such a force for good in the world
that i he sort of hypnotized me into it
yeah from talking to everybody it
definitely sounds like he knew how to
handle everyone to make them feel better
about what they were doing
yeah no he's he's
i mean i mean you are
you're a wrangler as a director
and i guess you want that responsibility
to
as long as you're not a megalomaniac the
best directors everything is done in
as a community he creates an incredibly
warm community
and and he's also very able to say i
don't know what the idea is so i will we
will discuss this as a
as a group rather than he's not a
dictator
um both sides of those can work but oh
my god what a warm and generous man and
i can guarantee you every single person
on that set
loved him
like no [ __ ] loved him did you have
a moment when you felt like you'd really
nailed robert evans i mean
i can tell that you know i can tell you
that just as an audience member it's
so insane to watch what you do in this
role but did you ever feel comfortable
and confident that
this had really sort of worked its way
into your bones
um
dexter started me off on that road i
guess i guess is that the
it's so difficult talking about it
without sounding like an idiot
but but really and truly i think it
wasn't it's not necessarily about what i
do it's like
but i watched i've watched some of the
what it's not even the rough i watched
the rough cut and i was like oh god i'm
not sure and then i watched some of the
stuff that's now fully done
and i breathed the sigh of relief and
for the first time and
you know
on this project i was like
i'm quietly proud of that i'm really
proud of that because i'd you know i'm
not sitting there watching rushes every
evening and thinking thank god that's
just not how i work you know i just
so
yeah when when did i think i finally got
him people had said some nice stuff
along the way but when i when i saw how
i how i merged and melded with everyone
else's performances because you can't
really highlight one performance in this
there's so many
really i know it sounds really silly but
it's it's true the the sum of the parts
is everybody so
um yeah when i saw some of it
how did you find the accent did you have
a dialect coach for that how did you
work through figuring that out
i did i well i spent a month and a half
um at home because i was still waiting
to i had to wait a long time to get a
visa i actually had to get to go to
budapest
um
because it was locked down to get my
american visa and i was there for sort
of eight days in a hotel where i'm going
oh god but it allowed me to spend a lot
of time just listening to his voice i've
just spent hours listening to him and he
saw and it wasn't difficult it was an
easy listen because
um
he just said some of the most some of
his interviews are just sort of
spellbinding in their honesty most of
the time
so
i put i was lucky enough that i think
you know whatever whatever just the red
the sheer repetition of it and then me
at some point you have to commit and so
i would sense because i wasn't able to
be in rehearsals i felt like i should i
will distance myself from the cast if i
don't do some homework so i would send
stuff and then little did i know until i
got there that dexter was showing it to
some of the other casts which i was like
oh thanks a bunch for that um
so yeah so it's just a lot of work and i
and i did i was a lovely lovely lady who
uh who was
helping the cast with with voices and i
had
she was great i had i had i had an hour
and a half with them she said you're
absolutely fine just go off and do it
i was like and that gave me a lot of
confidence too so that was nice i love
how each of these characters are really
sort of the hero to someone and the
villain to someone depending on
what is going on in any moment yeah
exactly yeah i mean if someone wants
something from them and they say no
they're the villain if someone wants
something from them and they say yes
they're the heroes so
what do you enjoy about playing someone
like that who really could
make someone's dream come true or end
their career well i think colin was very
colin hanks shanks that's what i'd like
to call him um
so the various stupid points about that
earlier on and that is
although you can think about his comp
because he plays a composite character
of many different people who were the
naysayers about that project at the time
they had very good reasons for saying no
it's only because we can view this from
where we are now that we can say
there's a lot of reasons that brando
could have been a massive disruption on
this film there's many many different
that strata that this could have been
this could have been a disastrous film
we never heard of francis for copper
again it's just that this weird alchemy
happened
and and it had already
and he will go down as the greatest
physical producer of all time or should
do considering he saw he put out so many
fires this film should have been a
disaster it shouldn't have been finished
um
and that's why it goes down as one of
the greats because and that's oftentimes
how can we reproduce
great films sometimes there needs to be
massive amounts of duress
and a lack of funding and
you know and angst and everything else
if you got a film
and unfortunately now because of many
reasons the 40 million film which i
think would probably be what that would
be equivalent to has disappeared for
many reasons of which we do not need to
get into but if you got a 40 million
film and and everything was easy and you
got your stars and there was no duress
it might it might well turn into a very
dull
film sometimes you need that kind of
friction
i don't know i don't know if i could
bottle it we would we'd all be
millionaires
with all the things you get to do
just through robert evans life through
just the interactions with marlon brando
and al pacino what was the most surreal
moment i'll tell you
let me tell you so i had a very very
surreal moment because okay first of all
i was working with justin chambers
who i
my very first job i met him in
luxembourg 20 years ago when he was he
was filming the three musketeers and i
was filming something that i dare not
speak the name
and and we there we were and then
suddenly
you have this like you do in life
sometimes like it's like how you learn
history you learn about the tudors when
you're eating and you learn about them
again um sort of 15 years later when
you're doing your a levels in a slightly
greater detail and in a slightly more
interesting time and that's how like so
once again i'm with justin
and we're sitting there and i'm playing
evans and he's playing marlon brando and
i'm like that's some pressure right
there and he does it
beautifully and he was great and i'm
watching him work and i'm like
so brilliant like i'm doing the scene
but we're still within the scene you're
like i'm so proud of him he's doing
really well and then adam came in adam
cut and i was like
i thought he was doing really well and
he goes adam
rather adam said to justin says justin i
want you to uh
eat those onion rings just a bit slower
just a little slower and i was like
funny funny bit of direction
and he does and so we start the take
again and adam was bang on because he
was eating them just because he was
obsessed with food brenda he was he was
eating them too quickly but by he
suddenly started
like
like they were some delicious sweet and
taking his time with it and i and
suddenly i forgot my lines because i was
so absorbed he had he became brando
and that was and i you can ask anyone
about it i i pontificated about it on
set probably too much i was like you
really got it you're already nailing him
um
yeah he was amazing
and and and and in fairness also to
anthony who played
uh pacino
i mean he
looked the way he got his voice i mean i
was that goes that gives me goosebumps
it's amazing there's so much good stuff
in this
yeah i mean you're also brilliant in it
so thank you for talking about it i just
was fascinated by it
it's funny it's good it's not bad this
yeah no it's it's so cool so thank you i
appreciate this my pleasure thank you
very much
you